few original residents from the time of
the nakba are still alive the claudette
habash is one
this is your house this is my house this
is my home
this is where i was born
and this is where i lived until the age
of seven
claudette spent a happy childhood here
until her family fled during the nakba
my father took us for security
with four children not even to take our
clothes not even to take our toys
nothing
so everything everything was left inside
the house the furniture your toilet
everything everything and you you never
got them back
nothing they were just acquired yes
these styles were put by my father
these doors are still the original doors
and the main door the entrance to the
home
to my home
is still the same
but i feel bad it is not well kept
it's very badly kept
oh
if you eat something without it being
washed
yeah yeah too right this is so this is
fruit from a tree that your father
planted my father planted this one yes
i did not forget i was seven years old
i did not forget i still remember and
vividly
my life my daily life here
then
my children
we made sure they know the history
the history of
my nation the history of the
palestinians and the history of our
properties of our home of my home the
home of my husband
and not
only my
grandchildren and i have two
great-grandchildren
they know when they pass from here they
say this is the home of theta this is
the home of sido
we make sure they do not forget
we are ready for reconciliation
but with justice
we want peace
but without justice how can you have
peace
it's a dream
and as long as we're here
and we are here
me and my palestinian people
it's hard to imagine isn't it having to
flee your home then you try and go back
again and to have the door
slammed in your face at home perhaps
you've lived in
as a family and with your ancestors for
generations but that
is the reality
for hundreds of thousands of
palestinians
well to establish the state of israel
zionist paramilitary groups had to
capture more land and in to do that they
launched a series of attacks across
what was historical palestine back then
well more than 530 main palestinian
villages were destroyed by jewish
paramilitary forces they drove out
entire populations from their homes
families were made refugees overnight
a thriving palestinian village tantora
another coastal village the port city of
jaffa tiberius the northern city of
haifa the list can go on they're just
some of the places where palestinians
were forcibly expelled
well haned is the general director of
the palestinian forum for israeli
studies
she explains how the expulsions of
palestinians from their lands
impacted families
it's the
it's mean to me what's mean for many
palestinians the laws of the homeland
the intimacy with the police are the
collapse of the society of the
palestinian society and the failure
actually of the national project and the
dream that the palestinian has before 48
is the it's the smashing devastation
and elimination
and ongoing
elimination of the palestinian existence
and wholeness it's the fragmentation
it's the shattering
of the people into different groups and
also it's the continual and ongoing
injustice of feeling that a jews from
anywhere can come and live in pakistan
and go to live even in the settlement
why the palestinian who
originally is from palestine turned to
be a refugee in 48 he cannot come and
visit sometimes
i don't think that there is one family
in palestine one palestinian family who
was not impacted in a direct meaning by
the
by shattering the family my family is is
is is in a place that was crossed
in 1948
by the new border so the family of my
father was turned to be in the other
side of the border the great what become
the the green line and my
other half of the family is into the
green line so my family in order just to
connect my grandfather to see his mother
was sneaking and filtering into the
border taking drex to be killed just to
meet her seven eight nine